imaginez deux hommes qui se battent dans
un parc
l'un d'eux tire un coup de feu et sans
fil une caméra de surveillance a
enregistré son visage en 20 minutes la
police de lyndiane à a résolu la mais
ses enquêteurs ont eu de l'aide
un logiciel qui s'appelle clé review
haye et qui se présente comme une
technologie pour aider à résoudre les
affaires les plus complexes
sauf que clear view est très critiqué
depuis une enquête du new york times
mi-janvier quand les policiers lui
soumettre une photo
le logiciel la compare avec plus de 3
milliards d' images récupérées sans
consentement sur facebook twitter
linkedin et des millions d'autres si
c'est lui le fondateur de cette petite
entreprise qui brasse très large
selon lui toutes les images disponibles
sur internet son public et son logiciel
les index et c'est une manne pour les
forces de l'ordre qui n'ont généralement
accès qu'à des photos de permis de
conduire ou d'arrestations c'est
scandaleux a dit l'ancien commissaire à
la vie privée de l'ontario parce que la
police de toronto a reconnu avoir
utilisé la technologie l'automne dernier
mais son chef a demandé de tout arrêté
début février et ce sont maintenant les
autorités du canada du québec de la
colombie britannique et de l'alberta qui
veut l'enquêté les commissaires à la vie
privé examineront si les pratiques de
l'organisation sont conformes aux lois
canadiennes sur la protection des
renseignements personnels près de 600
corps de police ont utilisé le logiciel
de clear view et l'année dernière
principalement en amérique du nord au
québec
là est ce qu est le spvm ont clairement
indiqué que cet outil ne faisait pas
partie de leur arsenal ici mathieu prost
radio canada montréal